[Music]
let's talk about classic chrome
[Music]
recently i made two new sony film
simulations one is a replica after the
fujifilm classic chrome film simulation
and the other one is a picture profile
made after the original kodachrome 64
film stock and in this video i'll
explain in detail the main
characteristics and differences between
the fujifilm and the sony classic chrome
let me know in the comments if you want
to find out more about the kodachrome 64
film simulation and i'll make another
video about it before we start remember
all sony film simulation recipes can be
found on my website
let's start with the classic chrome
this sony picture profile was made after
the fujifilm simulation and i used the
fuji xs10 to compare the two sample
clips as you can see they look very
similar with some slight differences
they are identical in terms of contrast
fuji seems to have a better dynamic
range but with worse noise performance
and in terms of color it's about 90
matching which is a pretty good result
taken into consideration i was able to
do this in camera only with the use of
the picture profile settings
as you can see the sony is much much
cleaner and has more details than the
fuji which seems pretty muddy
because of the light gathering
capabilities of the sony a73 the sensor
captures about a stop more light than
the fuji
so i had to lower down the exposure by
one stop to match the brightness in the
two cameras which again will give the
sony much cleaner results and has a
clear advantage here
unfortunately with the cine1 game on
sony the dynamic range seems to be a
little bit lower than the fuji at first
glance but one thing to remember is that
the cine1 gamma is the low light profile
and has 109 output which means you can
recover 9 of the print highlights and
i'll show you exactly what i'm talking
about
as you can see in this image it seems
like the highlights are completely blown
out but if we start to recover the
highlights and the shadows we can see
that it actually contains more detail
and has higher dynamic range than
initially seemed like and remember this
is only 8-bit on 10-bit cameras you'll
have a better color rendition and even
less noise
you could set the profile to cd4 to
increase the dynamic range inside the
camera but the noise performance lowers
considerably and the colors shift a lot
especially the yellow shift towards
green and skin tones towards pink which
for me personally is a big no-no
in theory the c4 skin tones can be
easily corrected in camera just by
lowering the color face to let's say -2
and that will shift the reds a little
bit more towards orange but that will
change the whole color spectrum shifting
the yellows even closer to green and i
honestly just don't like that for a look
from my experience the yellow is the
most problematic of all colors
especially on the sony's that's why some
companies like canon choose to
desaturate their yellows inside the
camera to run their perfect skin tone
also fun fact
yellow doesn't even exist at least not
how we see it
the human eye can only capture colors of
red blue and greens yellows and magentas
are actually generated by the brain
if you don't mind the color shifting of
the c4 you can definitely use it instead
of cine one for higher dynamic range but
only in well-lit conditions
in low light situations i find the cd4
to be quite noisy without applying some
noise reduction so besides that let's
take a closer look at the colors
the sony reds are shifted towards pink
while fuji is more orange the sony
greens are more olive while fuji greens
are shifted towards cyan and the yellows
are very close fuji being shifted
towards orange while sony looking more
accurate real life the rest of the
colors are more or less identical
overall i would rate this profile 90
identical to the fujifilm and you know
we were really paying close attention to
the color differences but when shooting
in a real-life situation it might not
even be that obvious we still get really
nice colors out of the camera
but still let's bring it even closer to
the fujifilm colors and i'll show you
exactly how to further adjust it in
davinci resolve for a perfect match
so in the color tab in the hue versus
hue menu shift the red stores orange
next take the greens and shift them just
a little bit towards cyan
now drag the yellows just a little bit
towards orange
[Music]
and finally shifted cyan
[Music]
now let's see the final result
it's almost indistinguishable to save
you some time i will upload this slot on
my website so you can download it for
free
that's pretty much all i want to show
you about the classic chrome let's move
on to the quarter chrome 64 a film stock
that is more interesting to me and that
is because replicating the quarter
chrome 64 was without any doubt my most
difficult and biggest challenge of
replicating any film stock
let me know in the comments if you want
me to talk about the kodachrome 64 film
simulation and i'll make a video about
it till next time have fun and take care
see ya
[Music]